these images are from a central train
station in buenos aires
the amount of people here could be one
of the reasons why
coronavirus infections have skyrocketed
in argentina in the past days
on wednesday argentina's government
confirmed over 22
000 new infections of covet-19 and
that's why president alberto fernandez
announced new measures to prevent the
spread of the virus
in these months we want to help health
care aid economic recovery and keep
schools open as much as we can
if we do this we can diminish the speed
of transmission the higher the
transmission and the hospital occupation
the more restrictions we will have to
impose and that's why we need to protect
ourselves
fernandez also announced a curfew at
midnight
restrictions on public transport and
social gatherings in private homes
last year argentina was one of the first
countries in the region to impose a
total
lockdown to prevent the spread of the
virus but the situation is different now
argentina's government is trying to
avoid imposing a total lockdown mostly
because
of the impact it would have on
argentina's fragile economy where
millions are struggling
to make ends meet and that's why it's
focusing on analyzing caseload
data imposing short-term restrictions
and getting hospitals ready
to cope with a second wave the long
lines of people at this testing site
show mounting concerns with the rising
infections
but most of those we spoke to say they
cannot afford to stay home
it's impossible to close everything it's
impossible i hope they move forward with
the vaccination campaign and we can move
forward
this is a delicate time for president
alberto fernandez
who tested positive a few days ago some
two months
after receiving the russian sputnik v
vaccine
later this year argentina will hold
midterm elections
and he will have to defend his party's
majority in congress
since the lengthy lockdown last year its
popularity has been bruised
by a shortage of vaccines and economic
troubles exacerbated by the pandemic
i would imagine that the solution is
going to be very flexible very much
handled in the day to day
and that it will be managed by different
levels of government
the national provincial and for the city
of buenos aires
the coordination of some restrictions
will be necessary without restraining
the economy
argentina like most emerging economies
is finding it tough to come up with cash
for pandemic relief efforts unlike many
wealthier countries
and that's why international
organizations like pajo
express concerns about the mounting
cases in this part of the world
because they know economic difficulties
pose
a challenge when it comes to fighting
disease
teresa al jazeera buenos aires